Guild Wars 2 living world episode 6 is
out so you need to get into it every new
episode that is released continues and
expands the ongoing saga and world of
Guild Wars 2 which is why they call it a
living world new story is added to
extend the lore of the world
new zones are added to extend the land
new mounts are added to explore the new
zones with new approaches new weapons or
armor are added so you can beat up the
new things that populate the new places
and new ways now let's check out the
newest Guild Wars 2 episode or eternal
if you haven't played Guild Wars 2 yet
or if you came in the middle of the
story here's a quick catch up you're the
commander a name you got from your time
leading an alliance known as the pact
and while you now work outside of the
packs chain of command you and your
allies have taken on the task of
protecting the land of Tyria from all
the evil that has threatened it and
there's been a lot of evil on top of
murderous villains undead tyrants and a
rogue god the people of Tyria have had
to deal with big-ass evil Elder Dragons
eating everything or destroying anything
they want
and then eating it
I told you and your allies are reeling
from an apparent defeat at the claws of
one of the worst of these Elder Dragons
Krakatoa in the last living world
episode all or nothing you and your
allies a group made up of all the races
on Tyria played by an amazing cast of
voice actors have planned what was
supposed to be the final fight against
crowd of torque in which you use your
friend or een a cute little blue dragon
who is the granddaughter of Krakatoa to
exploit his weaknesses prophet work is
powered by crystalline resonance and it
can be used to destroy him like using
Reiki healing as a weapon or een as the
same frequency as her grandfather and
can get through his crusty purple
crystal that makes him invulnerable if
you played the last episode you
definitely don't need to be told that
the story just took a turn for the what
the hell do we do now but if you didn't
just know that Irene was predicting her
own death at the hands of crown
Catterick for some time and well she was
right after an epic fight that you need
to play through if you haven't all the
plans all the preparation all the
sacrifices that you and the Allies have
made seem to come to an end in a flash
of purple and white dragon breath energy
stuff finalizing with a cute little blue
crystal dragon who looks way too crystal
ish to be healthy this episode opens
with Krakatoa
running from the last fight because
arena really did get through his gruff
exterior revealing the purple coward
beneath he isn't out of the fight yet
though he opens a portal and travels
into a magic realm between realms known
as the mists and you follow him to
hopefully in this fight for good the
Guild Wars 2 store is definitely what
pulled me in and after last episodes
ending I desperately needed to get back
to finish it but ArenaNet doesn't stop
with just adding story to each episode
they release additional new content like
zones and fractals what Guild Wars calls
instances as well as gear and mounts
that sometimes have their own storylines
to discover the new Zone in this episode
is called Dragon fall it's a mash-up of
landmasses that were floating peacefully
through the mists until Crockett ork
literally knocked them into another
world and they crashed together making
an island mismatch of different biomes
magic jungles full of magic creatures
who want to kill you purple crystal
areas full of purple crystal creatures
who want to kill you
and fiery forests full of fiery
creatures who want to kill you it's a
whole bunch of fun
also the ArenaNet team definitely flexes
on building immersive landscapes just
look at this stuff the new mountain this
episode is called the sky scale and it's
a freaking dragon I named mine
schnookums
with the new mountain guild wars you can
learn additional skills and abilities
that will add to or completely change
the way you move around Tyria for
instance the sky scale can obviously
glide through the air and gain altitude
by flapping its wings because it's a
freakin dragon but this is the first
Mountain Guild Wars that can hover it
can also do sweet tricks like a barrel
roll and if you need to take a breather
the sky scale can just grab some wall
and chill out until you recharge your
energy and are ready to get back out
there flying again to get your own
schnookums you'll get to have an
adventure going through each step of the
sky scales rearing and at the end get to
fly off with your own the new legendary
weapon that was added in war eternal is
a great sword called exordium it's a
shape-shifting blade meaning that its
appearance shifts based on the attack
you are using for example it becomes a
side that you're doing a sweep attack
and will turn into an ion cannon for a
beam attack it's a weapon for those who
like to have the right tool for each job
but don't want to actually get a
different tool for each job
if you're a veteran of Guild Wars 2 who
hasn't played in a while or you've never
heard of it before the game is great to
just pick up and go if you don't want to
play alone the active community is one
of the best parts of the game as always
big shout out to my guild VIP thank you
so much for watching and I'll see you
from the back of schnookums
[Music]